les contrats aidés on en parle depuis
des mois et de façon plus soutenue dans
le secteur de l'éducation nationale mais
il ya aussi ces contrats dans la vie
associative des associations et des
entreprises pour l'insertion qui était
monté au créneau on s'en souvient l'an
dernier à pareille heure bonjour jean
françois du lem
bonjour vous êtes le porte parole du
collectif des associations pour les
contrats aidés sauf si je me trompe
jean-françois du lem
on n'a pas beaucoup entendu les
associations qui elles aussi ont recours
à ces contrats aidés ça se passe mieux
que pour les collègues de l'éducation
nationale qui se seront que je pense que
la plupart des associations là
aujourd'hui nous même pas la force de
crier c'est plutôt ça c'est très à la
réalité et les problématiques sont assez
différentes
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on bon on
parle des contrats aidés ctm et de
contrat et d éducation nationale
bon un peu moins de 6 ans voilà les
problématiques de financement ne sont
pas les mêmes ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui au niveau des associations
nous sommes en train de jouer notre
survie parce que très clairement les les
dispositifs sont mis en place dans un
pays qui n'a pas les mêmes contraintes
que les que le nôtre est ici et ça nous
sommes en train d'essayer de faire
entendre notre voix là dessus maintenant
au score des spécificités qu'il faudrait
prendre maintenant migration wissal
lorsque c'est structurel
ça devrait déjà être pris en compte ça
veut dire qu'en france aujourd'hui il
fonctionne avec cette lutte au sein de
chômage c'est ici mais s'ils sont à jour
chez les jeunes on a theme bon les 25
25%
je viens alors que chez nous
structurellement c'est 30 % de taux de
chômage c'est 60% le chômage chez les
jeunes ça veut dire que le tissu
associatif a un rôle structure et
d'amortisseur social qui est extrêmement
important donc lorsque nous voyons la
légèreté avec laquelle la problématique
du financement des associations est
posée ça ça nous interpelle
on va faire très rapidement un état des
lieux il y à combiers de contrats aidés
dans ce secteur associatif en martinique
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui le secteur
associatif c'est un stock d'à peu près
4000 contrats et des tapirs eu d'accord
oui et puis maintenant il ya des
renouvellements régulièrement
d'accord il ya des renouvellements
régulièrement et cette année il ya eu
très peu loin nouvellement pourquoi
parce que il ya eu pour nous ce qui est
très difficile à vivre une diminution du
taux de prise en charge par l'état que
les gens comprennent un contrat aidé
secoirs contrats aidés c'est un poste au
sein de l'association pour lequel à ce
que l'état finance une partie
c'est une subvention of america 75% à 75
80 % hockey est là depuis cette année
ses 50 % il appartient à l'association
de trouver le complément les 50%
restants en général c'est ce que
l'association soit une collectivité
voilà il ya des stratégies différentes
en guadeloupe
la région guadeloupe a décidé d'apporter
le complément jusqu'à 80% pour les
associations
bon il n'y a pas eu le même type de
réponse en martinique il nous et puis
les les municipalités son exemple
la cdm à des contraintes financières
aujourd'hui donc ok mais nous on nous
avons un job à fait au niveau des
associations faut que tout le monde
comprenne bien que le fait que la
martinique puisse continuer à tenir
malgré des taux de chômage aussi
important d'accord c'est parce qu'il y
ait un tissu associatif dense c'est
parce qu'il y à des bénévoles dans le
sport dans la culture sud on au niveau
des quartiers qui s'investissent qui
fait que ça n'a pas encore péter
d'enjamber les associations qui ne
peuvent pas demander tout tout tout et
tout encore ces mêmes bénévoles du
hockey
ces contrats sont nécessaires est-ce que
vous avez des retours d'associations qui
disent tout simplement morphing épices à
nous cacher sa a nommé c'est clair bien
sûr aujourd'hui c'est à dire que alors
vous trouvez une situation où déjà on
nous de vos jeux lui contre les défauts
légère et derrière ce sont les salariés
il faut gérer derrière bon le bénévole
qui devient par hasard présidents
d'associations john paulson de notes il
se retrouve brusquement chef
d'entreprise avant qu'il n'a aucune
notion de la chose c'est à dire que les
exigences vis-à-vis des administratifs
vis-à-vis d'une association sont les
mêmes connu qu'un que pour une
entreprise donc déjà faut savoir que
l'association doit se structurer et se
structure et ça veut dire qu'il ya aussi
des coûts à ce niveau la langue est le
premier élément à établir une feuille de
paie par exemple ce n'est pas si facile
que ça c'est donc une notion exactement
bon et donc dans l'ia qu'elle je suis
plus plus président
l'insertion par l'activité économique ma
chaque association potes de l'ias est
une petite entreprise d'accord
simplement aller elle est non lucrative
de non lucratif ça veut dire que qu'il
n'y a personne
les dirigeants de l'association ne se
partage pas d'argent d'accord
contrairement à une entreprise qui est
souvent des exils pour pour lesquels il
ya souvent des exigences qui sont moins
importants que pour nous recevrons les
contrats aidés par exemple il ya tout un
suivi administratif un tas de choses à
mettre en place comme ce qui est demandé
aux associations à gaz c'est une vraie
usine à gaz pour lesquels les dirigeants
de l'association de la bleue plus en
plus se professionnaliser d'accord on
est prêts à jouer le jeu à ce niveau là
on la joue et on la joue et un singe
mâle et de vos assertions par l'économie
toutes les associations culturelles
sportives qui font ça parce qu'ils ont
envie de créer une école de danse dans
tel quartier etc
c'est pas toujours évident ça toutes les
associations
à des degrés divers se sont organisés
pour pouvoir répondre à ces existences
exigences là parfois dans la douleur
parce que c'était des révolutions
culturelles mais en tout cas elles ont
fait le job les bénévoles ont fait le
job d'accord et également les salariés
d'associations ont fait le travail mais
aujourd'hui on nous coupe l'herbe sous
le pied ça veut dire a résumé la
situation l'état qui baisse sa notation
les collectivités qui n'ont pas l'argent
pour apporter le complément déjà et puis
ensuite c'est vrai qu'on se sent un peu
très seul même au niveau des politiques
nos politiques tous tout prêts tout
couac tous bords confondus qui aurait pu
porter ça au niveau au niveau national
dans les négociations une chose pour
projet qu'ils font pas le job
hier c'était contre la pauvreté et
n'avoir pas avancé la peur déconne etc
les élus ont beau dos finalement vous
savez moi je veux pas avoir ce type de
responsabilité j'en ai d'autres niveaux
administratifs je ne présente pas aux
élections parti au moment où je dis je
vais représenter la collectivité ça veut
dire que je l'accompagnent sur les
différents dossiers le concernant
là on n'est pas au losc on par
l'association ans martinez compare pas
de quelque chose de marginal on parle de
quelque chose de structurant même les
entreprises qui à un moment donné
souvent on entend dire on entend des
chefs d'entreprise dire que des
associations font du comment dirais-je
de la concurrence déloyale et cetera il
s'opposa aux contrats aidés mais je dis
aux joueurs anthony ce discours là où
vous voulez en martinique ça c'est du
pipeau
pourquoi parce que pourquoi l'emploi
puisse plus fonctionner ouvrir tous les
jours il faut un climat social apaisé
dans un pays où ça pète dans tous les
sens aucun business le fonctionnel en
train de l'est aujourd'hui ce sont les
associations qui tiennent ce rôle là
sinon on renforce les forces de police
vous êtes en train de dire jean françois
du lem que si on ne règle pas si
rapidement cette question de des
contrats aidés ne serait ce que dans les
associations est bien celle ci ne
pourront plus jouer sur ce lien social
et puis dans cinq dix ans ces jeunes qui
auraient pu être accueillis qui n'ont
pas été accompagnés structure et
risquent de se retrouver dans la rue
sous les kiosques mais j'aime ça risque
de faire mal c'est un jeu pas faire de
catastrophisme mais les gamins qui font
du sport c'est qu'avec qui font du sport
avec des associations sportives
lorsqu'ils sont dans le quartier pour
qu'ils aient des animations pendant les
vacances c'est pas au départ qui par des
associations
lorsqu'après ils sont en situation
d'exclusion d'accord où il s'agit de
faire un accompagnement paul de
réinsertion s'est porté par qui par des
associations
lorsque les associations n'ont pas les
moyens de faire ça ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire on enlève quelque chose qui
est déterminant pour tout être humain
l'espoir ça veut dire que les jeunes qui
sont accueillis dans les différents
dispositifs d'insertion y compris la
station pratique vite économique est ce
qu'on leur redonne confiance en eux et
l'espoir de diogo dm demain il peut y
avoir autre chose
si vous enlevez ça la bonne pavot alors
je reçois du lem il ya ce combat mené
par les organisations syndicales au
niveau de l'éducation nationale il ya eu
cette rencontre hier avec le recteur les
organisations syndicales qui verront à
partir de mercredi de demain la suite à
donner
mais pourquoi il n'y a pas une
convergence comme ce fut le cas l'an
dernier de ces contrats et d éducation
nationale et vie associative pour être
plus forts a composé de l'être davantage
benz avait l'an dernier
ca c elle s'est faite à la convergence
ne s'est pas faite defacto dès le départ
mais quand je lui ai dit les
problématiques sont différentes en ce
qui me concerne déjà à bombay c'est à
dire que le jeu pour moi les contrats
aidés dans l'éducation nationale
d'accord c'est une entourloupe du
gouvernement d'accord ça veut dire que
le gouvernement veut supprimer ça le
gouvernement n'en est pas du tout mais
nous sommes sur des postes qui sont des
dépôts structurelles
d'autres leaders dans les écoles ont
besoin pour fonctionner d'accord et on
met des contrats précaires de suite moi
je fais de la gestion l'austro finances
du long terme avec av
avec des ressources qu'aux termes on a
un problème on a besoin formellement
d'accord ben bella ils ont des emplois
long termes structurels structurant pour
les établissements et l'état mais des
emplois aidés dessus d'accord donc déjà
ça ccc c'est n'importe quoi
l'état n'a rien et chaque année il ya
les mêmes promet nan mais c'est
volontaire
c'est volontaire parce qu'il s'agit de
précariser nous sommes dans une logique
de précarisation et ils préfèrent mettre
des emplois précaires là dessus chaque
année il faut se battre à nouveau pour
eux alors que les besoins dans les
écoles ils sont là les cpe ils ont
besoin ils ont besoin
ils ont besoin de cet accompagnement il
ya besoin de ces accompagnements pas
tous is in il invente uriel et ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui au niveau l'éducation
nationale c'est pas du luxe qui demande
ce sont les conditions minimales pour
pouvoir assurer le job et l'encadrement
cadreront des gammes pas des
associations dans les associations
jean-françois du lem est ce que tout
simplement au lorsque membres vient
payer sa cotisation ce devient licenciés
et serra est ce que cette association
n'a pas tout simplement intérêt à
répercuter sur le prix de la licence ou
de la cotisation abbas qu'il faudrait
pour avoir ces contrats aidés mais c'est
ce que le gouvernement demande
aujourd'hui le gouvernement demande en
toile de fond de toutes ces décisions
gouvernementales c'est quoi nous sommes
lents dans une cécile un système
marchand qui est mis en place on nous
demande d'accord de facturer aux petits
aux parents du petit jeune qui va venir
jouer au football
le coût effectif de sa peau bien que ça
paie ça combien marcos les coûts réels
d'accord du d'une année de football ou
d'une année de basket ou d'une allée des
scream alors se retrouver dans des
licences à 500 600 euros minimum minimum
d'accord bon l'état se décharge de sa de
cette partie là qui est de l'éducation
que 10 des bénévoles ont pris en charge
et tout sur le mode est un complément de
financement
merci jean françois du même d'avoir été
avec nous on va peut-être vous êtes
porte parole de l'association du
collectif des associations pour les
contrats aidés bonne journée